I don't want to be just the person in
computerphile who does all the history
and nothing but history I'd actually
like to do some programming with you and
some of you in the comments what she
said why don't you do Java or teach us
some C or something and I thought no
I've got a very good opportunity here to
lead off from the PostScript story
that's I've been telling and actually do
some PostScript programming with you
it's pretty easy to get software both
for Linux for Mac and for PC that will
enable you to run of the programs as I
develop with you and even create ones of
your own and I think that's important
it's no use me getting into some
language where the support is utterly
minimal PostScript was invented ass
Adobe by John Warnock and a team of co
helpers it built on work that he'd done
several years earlier when he worked
with the Evans & Sutherland graphics
company I think he'd done some more work
on it's in a language called Jam when he
was at Xerox PARC the M in Jam standing
for John John and Martin that's right M
is for Martin Newell anyway it became
fully fledged when it got to Adobe it's
a very big language it's got something
like 400 operators in all but I think
I've already said and let me emphasize
again it's far more than a
two-dimensional graphics language it is
a full-blown programming language it can
do anything as any other language can do
it can do anything that the Turing
machine can do and for that reason it's
called a Turing complete language we're
going to print out six instances of the
text computer file first of all I'm
going to do it with if you like a proper
conventional PostScript program and no
surprises in guessing that it will
involve a for loop that goes around six
times it's vital that you know something
about PostScript and how it works first
of all it's an interpreted language many
of you will know what that means it
means it's things like Perl Python
JavaScript for the older generation
among you it's things like lists
what it means if you have an interpreted
language is you look at what has been
requested in the program and you do it
there and then that way you gain great
flexibility
it doesn't necessarily run all that fast
that's the real challenge it's in the
very nature of PostScript that it uses a
notation called post fix and that in
turn relies for its execution
environment on this notion of a stack we
may be in a position to put this out as
a separate film in its own right this is
postfix I think his name is pronounced
on and like Yanukovych people being
unable to pronounce his name correctly
and getting all the stresses and accents
wrong decided that rather than
pronouncing what they found hard they
would call this polish notation now
actually polish notation applies to
using anything that isn't in fix I've
seen prefix notation being called
forward polish notation I've seen
postfix giving its traditional name of
reverse polish notation the stack is
last in first out storage the last thing
I put on the stack I pushed it on was
this little white one the only thing I
can directly get at at the top of the
stack is the same thing so it's the last
thing in and it's the first thing off
and the act of taking it off the stack
is called popping the stack so we'll
keep this to one side just to remind us
that PostScript is totally totally
stacked based in every single thing it
does and I'm now in a position that I
can actually go through the four loop
version of the program with you I'll be
talking about stacks until you're fed up
of hearing about them first of all
anything beginning percent in PostScript
is a comment there's a very special
comment right at the top of your post
group program which effectively invites
you to announce which version of adobe
postscript this program will be
compliant with
what I've said here is this requires
PostScript defined by Adobe
version 2.0 aught most of the time in
most PostScript interpreters nowadays
you don't really have to bother about
that minimum you can get away with is
just the percent and the exclamation
mark opinions differ as to whether
exclamation mark or typical shriek or
bang it's all from comic books you know
shriek exclamation mark exclamation mark
or bang lots of exclamation marks I
don't call it back so when I say % bang
it means it's the top of a postscript
program PostScript allows you to have
things like characters real numbers
integer numbers things of that sort that
you would expect it's not what is called
a strongly typed language you don't have
to tell PostScript here that six is an
integer it knows and it's fairly
cavalier about what it will let you do
with those but then it says if you ask
me to define six as being n which is
what this is doing then fine I'll regard
it as being an integer version of six if
you mean no six that I can print out on
the printer so it's the ASCII character
six then I will give you conversion
operators that will convert it into
printable strings so if it finds out
from context what it thinks is plausible
for the type of these things so here we
go look our first example use of reverse
polish PostScript notation /n means i
want to define a variable called n here
it is on the stack there's the six death
is a postcode operator which does
definitions in other words it binds a
value to a variable name so what this is
saying is make my integer variable n
represent the value 6 and it does that
by taking them off storing away n with
the value 6 inside it somewhere inside
postscript memory
now here's another wonderful example of
postscript postfix use first op around
this time the font name ocr-a so what
I'm saying to postscript here is you
know where the fonts are kept but I'm
using find one called ocra and push on
the stack of the name the font name
ocra when you found OCR a push on here
the required point size of it and the
operator this is called select font so
it binds this point size to this font
and says right that's what we're using I
think I said way way back and early on
that we might encounter conventional
programming constructs in PostScript and
we do this is a full loop but notice
it's in postfix the operand which is the
four comes last next to last in the
curly braces is a bunch of program that
we wish to execute every time we go
around this for loop the weird thing oh
it's maybe not all that weird actually
is that the start value the increment
value and the final value are specified
up at the top here so when you come to
think about it if you're only to promote
the for up to the top here it would look
a bit like Java or C but writing it out
this way okay you push the start value
you push the increment value and n the
terminating value but n has been defined
as six so it's saying basically stopping
a1 in steps of 1 up to 6 do the
following piece of program every time it
goes round what you can rely on
happening is that the current value of
the loop counter will be available to
you in the loop body every time round so
it will start off as 1 and I'll do the
loop then I will increment the 1 to
being a to choose this one for to next
try around the loop the loop cans will
be 2 but here's the really handy thing
it could be 2 but you can access that
value of 2 at the top of the stack every
time you look at the top of the stack
you can rely on having
current value of the loop counter there
what the loop is going to execute is 10
100 move - there's the operator here are
the operands so this one is the x
position and the default units are
typographic points and you all know
about that 72 points to the inch this
one is the Y position so all that's
happening here your coordinate system
starts down here at 0 0 it starts at the
lower left-hand corner and everything is
relative to here if I say move 10 in the
X Direction 2 there and move a hundred
in the Y direction to here that's about
an inch and a bit attend is about 1/7 of
an inch so roundabout there I will print
my first computer file to be fair you
sometimes find that you 0 0 gets a
little bit misaligned with the bottom of
the physical paper particularly if you
insist on printing onto a full size
paper as if it was us letter size paper
but I hope you get the idea here 0 0
we're gonna move a little bit in on the
x axis look a 7th of an inch about an
inch up between every instance of this
banner as we go up and every time we do
that move to we then gone to the next
aisle and it's just says show the string
computer file now the way you do strings
in PostScript is not with double quotes
like you would in Java or C you put them
in round brackets parenthesis so the
only thing now to say well alright it
goes around 6 times they get six
versions of computer file coming out
what on earth is all this and why are
you doing that first of all I say a
hundred mole Mull is going to say to
itself to have the multiply now want two
things to multiply together but do
remember I warned you or I told you that
at the top of the stack every time
around the loop is the current loop
counter value so the first time around
this is one
so basically I'm saying a hundred mole
and you say that's not enough operands
you need two operands from oh no I don't
because one of them is implicitly there
already at the top of the stack is a one
so I'm pushing a 100 on top of it take
this big one that represents something
big like a hundred I put it on top but
there's the one already there then I say
multiply so the answer is hundred times
one is a hundred and I push that back on
the top of the stack now the first time
around of course one times under is
trivial is 100 but the next time around
is going to be two times 100 which will
make 200 then three times 100 and so on
once I've got the correct Y position
calculated I'm going to use this black
one to represent the 10 and remember the
10 points is the X offset every time
okay so I've got now a hundred I've got
ten how many trouble is unfortunately
you don't want a hundred ten move to you
want 10 100 move to in other words if
I'd written 10 100 move to you stack the
10 you stack the hundred you do the move
to the bigger hundred is on top not
underneath why did it end up underneath
well it ended up there because I wanted
to do some calculation and I left it
behind as the answer but PostScript has
the answer if your operands on the stack
of the wrong way around you do the
exchange
the exch operator I've got a hundred and
ten
I need them the other way around well I
exchange them there well I've changed
what would have been a hundred ten moved
to into 10 100 moved to and don't forget
as you read left to right in all of
these things the 10 and the 100 the 10
gets pushed on the first the hundred
gets pushed on afterwards and that's
exactly the order in which move to
expect to find them he lifts them off
and it says
why value will be on top the x value
will be underneath that's the use of
exchange then to flip things around at
the top of the stack and from then on
you know everything is utterly
straightforward
okay so we've analyzed this PostScript
program now with a simple for loop
you're familiar with moving to a new
position on the page with the fact that
the show operator shows the immediately
preceding string of characters and that
there's another operator called select
font which can be used to decide which
font you're using and what point size
you want it at so there we are that's
the original full loop version of it
which has all the right effects the
interpreter I'm using the PostScript
clone interpreter is one of the most
famous ones it's called go script it was
originally written in the early 90s by a
guy called Peter Deutsch it's freely out
there one of the many things that's been
added to it over the years is a slightly
more powerful viewing front end as it
were called ghost view but ghost vu
still relies on go script underneath so
what I'm going to do now is to run ghost
view on the for loop version of the
program see the multi star crap okay so
that's the for loop and that produces
six computer files running up the page
we'd like to thank audible.com for
supporting us computerphile video and if
you'd like to check out one of their
huge range of books go to audible.com
slash computerphile and you can try one
for free today I'd like to recommend
Douglas Adams's book douglas adams did
The Hitchhiker's Guide to the galaxy
which I love and then rescued from his
computer after his sad death was a book
called the salmon of doubt so check that
out if you get the chance
so that's audible.com slash
computerphile you can try one for free
thanks them for supporting this video